Profª. Tamar Gendler: Tudo bem,
no contexto do curso,
esta é a nossa 2ª aula
sobre a punição.
Vocês se lembram que antes da
pausa estivemos pensando
em quais normas morais são adequadas:
Que tipo de princípio fundamenta
a nossa especificação
de normas morais?
E agora observamos o mesmo
grupo de perguntas
pelo lado oposto.
Nós observamos esse grupo de
perguntas a partir da perspectiva
do que ocorre quando alguém
viola essas normas,
tanto as normas morais qua ou normas
legais qua quanto as codificadas
no conjunto de estatutos
de uma sociedade.
E observávamos uma série de
justificações que podem ser oferecidas
para a prática da punição.
E comentamos de forma breve, e eu
vou falar um pouco mais hoje,
sobre 2 delas: a restituição
e a reabilitação.
Mas passamos a maior parte da 2ª metade
da aula de terça pensando sobre a
justificação retrospectiva,
que em muitos aspectos é semelhante
ao tipo de justificação
de constrangimento moral que vemos
na imagem deontológica.
O que eu quero fazer agora é
analisar a 1ª atentamente
e refletir sobre a aparência
da imagem prospectiva
ou consequencialista da punição.
E refletir sobre como os
problemas que emergem
para um modelo
consequencialista de
punição
parecem ecoar uma série de
problemas levantados
para um modelo consequencialista
da moralidade em geral.
Então, só para lembrá-los
com o que se parece
a caracterização da punição
que estamos trabalhando,
em que a cláusula mais
importante será a 1ª,
estamos usando a caracterização
clássica de punição
de meados do século passado,
advinda da tradição filosófica
jurídica anglo-americana.
E o que é fundamental entender na
justificação para a punição
segundo o ponto de vista
consequencialista
é que a punição é executada em
resposta a um delito legal,
é executada por julgar um
infrator, e assim por diante...
Mas também que, como parte do
que é a punição,
envolve a imposição de desconforto
e sofrimento para a pessoa que se
encaixa nas condições de 2 a 5.
E a questão que estamos
tentando responder
é como um Estado poderia
ser justificado
ao trazer a desutilidade deliberada
para um de seus membros.
Portanto, o que a redução de danos ou
a perspectiva consequencialista
diz é que o único objetivo, ou
a única justificação,
da punição é prevenir ou deter
uma infração futura.
O consequencialismo, na sua
forma mais pura,
está interessado ?apenas
nas consequências.
E na medida em que ele está
preocupado com a distribuição
de utilidade aos membros de uma
sociedade, o interesse é
maximizar a utilidade desde
esse momento em diante.
Ele é chamado direcionado
para o futuro porque,
embora considere o passado na medida
em que as memórias dos
indivíduos consideram o passado,
ele não considera o passado
como algo relevante
para o cálculo da utilidade.
O único objetivo da punição
é prevenir ou deter uma
infração futura.
E a única justificação
para a punição
é prevenir ou deter uma
infração futura.
Agora, se o utilitarismo serve
como justificação
para a punição como uma prática, a
punição trazendo deliberadamente
a desutilidade a um membro da comunidade
que tenha violado alguma norma moral ou
legal, então deve ser o caso,
para que ela seja justificada por
bases consequencialistas,
de que a punição é uma forma eficaz,
e, de fato, em alguns modelos,
que a punição é o
mecanismo mais eficaz
para a prevenção ou dissuasão
de infrações futuras.
Se existe alguma forma alternativa
que ofereça resultado
igualmente benéfico,
então ela não pode ser justificada
por bases consequencialistas
de impor dano ou sofrimento
a um indivíduo.
Isso é o que diz a imagem
consequencialista.
E observem: esta é a imagem espelhada
de algumas das hesitações
que nos vimos envolvidos em
casos como o do cirurgião,
onde se todos considerarem as
distribuições de utilidade,
então uma série de fatores
que entram no raciocínio do senso comum
parecem desmoronar no que diz
respeito à sua relevância.
A sugestão, se a hipótese
empírica é correta,
é que a punição é o
mecanismo mais eficaz
para a prevenção ou a incapacitação.
Ou seja, ele é a melhor maneira
de impedir a possibilidade de
infração por parte do autor
e/ou o melhor mecanismo para
impedir infrações,
seja por parte do indivíduo ou
de outras pessoas que
– como resultado de tornar pública
a prática da punição –
reconhecem isso que você
poderia entender
como a análise de custo-benefício
da realização de uma
determinada mudança de atitude.
Jeremy Bentham diz que...
Jeremy Bentham foi a antecessor
utilitário de John Stuart Mill,
a pessoa que originalmente articulou, na
tradição filosófica moderna,
como é que devemos entender
o consequencialismo.
Assim, Jeremy Bentham disse
que o que a punição faz
é mudar o cálculo
de custos e benefícios associado a um
determinado ato de infração
e atribuir a algo que geralmente é
benéfico algum tipo de custo,
de modo que isso possa
entrar no cálculo.
Na literatura sobre condicionamento e
reforço, a punição é algo
que muda as contingências
associadas a um ato particular.
Ela traz uma penalização
junto a uma gratificação
para algo que normalmente proporciona
apenas uma gratificação.
Ou ela reduz a gratificação associada
a algo que geralmente traz uma
gratificação alta.
Isso deve estar claro para todos vocês,
porque nós analisamos a imagem
espelhada disso no caso positivo,
que pensando apenas em termos de
justificativas consequencialistas
para a punição parece trazer
2 tipos de problemas.
O 1º é que a
justificação
consequencialista
parece subestimar razões
para a punição,
se lembrarmos que a punição envolve
a execução deliberada de um dano.
Por exemplo, pode ser que,
no que diz respeito à
questão da incapacitação,
que se o nosso único objetivo
seja incapacitar indivíduos
propensos a cometer crimes no futuro
que ocasionarão desutilidade para
a sociedade como um todo;
se o nosso único objetivo
é incapacitá-los,
então as alternativas não
punitivas podem ser eficazes.
Lembrem-se da condição 1 na nossa
caracterização da punição.
A punição envolve dor ou
sofrimento imposta pelo Estado.
Ela envolve a execução deliberada da
desutilidade para um indivíduo.
Presumivelmente, a simples
incapacitação
pode ser feita de uma forma que
não envolva nada mais
que a quantidade mínima de imposição
de sofrimento ao indivíduo.
Assim, qualquer quantidade
maior que o necessário
para a incapacitação não pode ser
justificada por essa base consequencialista.
Além disso, ao que parece, não apenas
em relação à prevenção,
há uma possibilidade de
incapacitação não-punitiva,
mas também no que diz respeito à
questão da dissuasão.
Presumivelmente, se a preocupação real
é reduzir o índice de criminalidade,
então existem coisas muito menos
caras que o sistema prisional,
para alcançar esse objetivo desejado.
Criar situações sociais em que
as pessoas tenham acesso
à educação e ao emprego pode –
uma questão empírica –
ser um meio mais eficaz de impedir o
crime que a punição pública.
Especialmente se uma das
consequências de prender
indivíduos,
muitos dos quais são pais,
é deixar a próxima geração
numa posição de estabilidade familiar,
que sabemos – das nossas
discussões anteriores –
ser o que permite às pessoas
terem almas bem-ordenadas.
Muitas crianças que
crescem em famílias
que não lhes oferecem esse
tipo de estabilidade
podem ter custos sociais.
Então deixa eu reiterar: essas
são questões empíricas.
É uma questão empírica se a forma
mais eficiente de incapacitação
é aquela que envolve a
imposição de mais sofrimento
que o necessário para a
incapacitação imediata.
Talvez isso tenha consequências
melhores a longo prazo,
em termos de prevenção
de crimes futuros.
Da mesma forma, talvez a forma
mais eficaz de dissuasão
seja um tipo de punição que
traga com ela uma publicidade
que faz com que os outros evitem
comportamentos do mesmo tipo.
Mas acontece que se a prevenção
requer incapacitação simples
e a dissuasão parece mais
eficaz por outros meios,
o consequencialismo não
pode nos oferecer
uma justificativa para a punição.
Portanto, o 1º problema com o
argumento consequencialista,
se o que estamos tentando encontrar é uma
justificativa para a punição,
é que ele é subestimador.
O 2º problema é que, em
determinados casos,
parece ser a
superestimação da
punição.
Então, isso parece
– e lemos sobre isso no artigo de
John Rawls da última aula –
autorizar o que às vezes é
chamado de telishment.
Onde telishment significa
concentrar-se no telos,
concentrar-se no objetivo,
concentrar-se no fim,
em vez de enfocar o processo.
Então, como isso funciona?
Aqui está um exemplo.
Eis uma comunidade de pastores.
Todos se parecem com Giges.
E aqui estão eles com os cavalos.
Entra em cena o nosso conhecido ladrão
e rouba 2 cavalos.
A polícia chega à procura dele.
E ele sai da cidade.
Então, não há ninguém para ser
punido por roubar os cavalos.
Pobre Jim, azarado, aparece
justo no instante
em que a polícia buscava um infrator.
E a polícia encontra uma
maneira muito eficaz
de prevenir o roubo futuro de cavalos;
talvez seja colocar o Jim na cadeia
e sair uma grande manchete no
jornal sobre isso:
"Ladrão de cavalos capturado!
Condenado à prisão perpétua."
Ou seja, o efeito de dissuasão que
a punição pede parece,
pelo menos em princípio,
como se em certos casos
pudesse ser realizado com a mesma
eficácia, trazendo punição,
ou algo como punição, para
carregar sobre um indivíduo
que não é de fato o que
cometeu o crime.
Se o objetivo é a dissuasão,
e se a hipótese de que a
divulgação da punição
é o que produz a dissuasão,
então parece que não há recursos
no repertório conceitual
do consequencialista para
negar o telishment.
Tal como ocorre com os casos típicos do
cirurgião fatiando o paciente,
o consequencialista pode executar
movimentos mais complicados.
E a sugestão não é que
seja impossível
dentro de um quadro consequencialista
descartar algo como o telishment.
O raciocínio é que
é importante deixar claro que os recursos
estão disponíveis para você,
se esta é a justificação para a
qual você está apelando.
E reconhecer que, pelo
menos à 1ª vista,
a justificação consequencialista
parece tanto subestimar quanto
superestimar coisas que se parecem
com a punição em casos onde,
pelo menos como codificado em nossos
estatutos legais herdados,
isso viola as normas a que
as pessoas se sentem
intuitivamente identificadas.
Então, como podemos
contornar esse problema?
Lembrem-se que havia
problemas, ao que parece,
com a imagem retribucionista e com a
imagem consequencialista.
Uma das formas padronizadas de
contornar isso é introduzir
o que poderia ser chamado de
teoria dos 2 níveis.
E vimos um exemplo de uma das
teorias dos 2 níveis
mais sofisticada e influente nas
nossas leituras da última aula.
John Rawls,
de quem vamos ouvir falar
novamente daqui a umas semanas,
o filósofo político, escreveu
em 1950 um artigo famoso
chamado "Two Concepts of Rules",
em que uma das coisas
analisadas é a punição.
E o que ele sugere é que
pensamos sobre o tema
da justificação para a punição
da forma mais complicada.
Que 1º pensamos sobre o que
justifica a própria prática:
O que torna legítimo para uma
sociedade ter a punição?
E a sugestão é que o que
justifica a prática em si mesma
é que dispor de tal prática é
uma utilidade social.
Mas uma vez que definimos a prática,
o que justifica as ações específicas
dentro da prática é a retribuição.
E ele sugere, mais tarde,
que pensemos nessa distinção
entre justificar uma prática e
justificar as ações de uma prática
em analogia a algo semelhante
às regras do beisebol.
Portanto, ao criar as
regras do beisebol,
podemos debater se o beisebol
seria um jogo melhor
com 3 ou com 4 strikes.
Se o beisebol seria um jogo melhor
com a permissão ou
proibição do roubo de bases.
Se o beisebol seria um jogo melhor
com os lançadores também sendo
rebatedores, ou não.
Esse é o debate sobre a
natureza da prática.
E podemos pensar que quando discutimos
sobre a natureza da prática,
uma espécie de
consideração entra em
jogo.
Mas uma vez que dispomos da prática,
não debatemos se um jogo seria melhor,
nesta situação em particular,
com o rebatedor tendo 4 strikes...
Ou se seria melhor, nesta
situação em particular,
se uma base roubada contasse ou não
como uma forma de avançar pelas bases.
Assim, podemos distinguir entre o
que define a nossa prática
e o que ocorre uma vez que a nossa
prática tenha sido definida.
E a sugestão de Rawls é que o
que justifica a prática
no caso da punição é um
quadro geral de utilidade,
enquanto que o que justifica os
atos dentro da prática
é algo como a retribuição.
E ele sugere que isso é
administrado simultaneamente
para resolver 2 problemas.
O problema da
subestimação, em algum
sentido,
porque se a prática
geral não é útil,
então ela será abandonada.
E resolve, de forma mais clara, o
problema da superestimação,
o problema do telishment,
porque ele é descartado como um
ato dentro da prática.
Nós definimos as regras do que
envolve a punição.
Aquelas que são justificadas
pelas bases utilitárias.
Mas dentro da prática não
podemos fazer coisas
como colocar o Jim na prisão como
uma forma de dissuasão,
já que isso é proibido pela prática.
Portanto, parece que o desafio
pluralista, ou a solução pluralista,
para o dilema de como a
punição pode ser justificada,
seja por bases retribucionistas
ou consequencialistas,
resolve o problema que nos preocupava.
Que é: como o Estado pode
ser justificado
em causar danos aos seus cidadãos?
Mas existem 3 questões que
ainda podem ser levantadas
em relação a essa solução.
Poderíamos perguntar se a
utilidade sozinha,
sem apelo à retribuição,
pode realmente servir como a única
justificação da prática ou se,
na verdade, o problema da subestimação
só vai ressurgir no nível da
justificação para a prática.
Podemos perguntar se a
retribuição sozinha,
sem apelar para a utilidade,
pode servir para justificar as
ações dentro da prática ou se,
em última análise, a fim de
captar o que nós queremos
que a punição faça, mesmo quando a
prática foi estabelecida,
requer algum apelo à retribuição.
E eu vou falar sobre a
psicologia disso daqui a pouco.
E, finalmente, podemos nos perguntar se,
dada a distinção dos 2 níveis,
nós oferecemos alguma coisa
como um relato coerente
do que justifica a punição.
Se um tipo de razão governa a prática
e outro tipo de razão regula a
aplicação da prática,
então, mesmo que cada uma
delas seja capaz
de fazer esse trabalho de forma
independente, na verdade,
especialmente se cada uma
delas for capaz de fazer
esse trabalho de forma
independente, é possível
ponderar
como as duas juntas oferecem
um relato coerente.
Portanto, isso encerra o meu comentário
sobre as questões filosóficas gerais
que fundamentam a punição
como uma prática.
Nós refletimos a partir de 2 das
justificativas padrão e,
em seguida, de uma 3ª que
tenta reconciliá-las.
E deixa eu lembrá-los mais uma vez
que parte do que estamos fazendo aqui
é pensar de modo mais geral sobre
a justificação moral.
Então, todos os argumentos
que temos considerado
no contexto da punição
têm análogos diretos na imagem
espelhada positiva disso.
O que eu quero fazer na
última metade da aula
é comentar sobre 3
questões adicionais.
Estas são as leituras que
fizemos para hoje.
Eu quero falar sobre a psicologia e
as restrições psicológicas
que parecem constranger
qualquer imagem de punição
que vamos ter.
Isso vai estar em conformidade
com como as pessoas
intuitivamente respondem
a situações particulares de
violação da norma.
Eu quero conectar o que temos
falado no contexto da punição
com o que falamos sobre sorte
no final das nossas aulas
antes do feriado.
E, finalmente, eu quero retornar a
alguns temas aristotélicos
sobre o caráter virtuoso, falando
sobre punição e parentalidade.
Portanto, nos últimos 30 anos ou mais,
tem aparecido um grande conjunto
de pesquisa empírica
realizada por psicólogos sociais
extremamente sofisticados
que observaram tantos as
respostas das pessoas
a casos hipotéticos quanto os códigos
legais de inúmeras sociedades
na tentativa de chegar, não
à questão normativa,
o que justificaria a punição,
mas a uma resposta para a
pergunta descritiva:
que necessidade psicológica
humana endereça a punição.
E ao explorar essas
questões, John Darley
– a quem já lemos trechos em
diversos momentos deste curso,
inclusive hoje –
apela para a própria distinção
que comentamos no que diz
respeito à questão normativa.
Você pode distinguir na busca
para ver que fatores
afetam as decisões das
pessoas sobre a punição,
se elas parecem ter a
atenção voltada apenas
para questões como deserto
e retribuição.
São questionamentos...
Será que afeta a probabilidade ou
a gravidade da punição
se o indivíduo em questão
tem a intenção de praticar muito dano,
independentemente de ele
ser bem-sucedido?
Será que afeta a avaliação das
pessoas sobre o mal causado
se o indivíduo, por exemplo,
rouba o dinheiro para dar a uma
instituição de caridade
em vez de comprar uma Ferrari?
São questionamentos sobre o que
passava na mente do indivíduo...
o indivíduo queria ou
não causar danos.
São questionamentos sobre os
objetivos da pessoa
m relação aos ganhos do crime –
a intenção é usá-los em algo
pró-social ou antissocial...
Então isso parece um dos
tipos de considerações
que emergem quando se
argumenta que a punição
se refere a coisas baseadas
na retribuição.
Em contrapartida,
se quando as pessoas pensam sobre o
tipo de punição imposta,
o foco delas são coisas como
qual a probabilidade de um
crime ser descoberto
ou quão público será o
ato da punição,
então parece que os mecanismos
psicológicos fundamentados
por trás da punição são aqueles
primariamente sensíveis
às restrições consequencialistas.
Portanto, numa série de estudos ao
longo das últimas décadas,
os psicólogos têm se perguntado:
a que tipo de variações os
julgamentos punitivos são sensíveis?
Em geral, quando as pessoas
atribuem a punição,
quando atribuem a gravidade,
quando as pessoas decidem se punir
ou não, será que elas,
se for dada a oportunidade de
checar as informações,
querem informações, por exemplo,
sobre o estado de espírito
do infrator ou sobre a
motivação do infrator?
Ou será que eles querem informações
sobre como a punição será
amplamente divulgada
ou qual a probabilidade desse tipo
de crime ser descoberto?
E acontece algo bastante
consistente que é:
as considerações do 1º tipo
parecem conduzir as
respostas das pessoas.
Ou seja, um cálculo utilitário
não parece ser a principal motivação
quando os indivíduos pesquisados
??em estudos de psicologia,
ou códigos penais, são analisados
conforme as indicações
do mecanismo psicológico que
fundamenta a punição.
E vemos mais uma evidência a
favor dessa hipótese,
se considerarmos o fenômeno que
isso às vezes é conhecido
como punição altruísta ou
onerosa de terceiros.
Portanto, esses são os casos em
que um indivíduo, A, pune
(ou seja, causa danos e custos
a) outro indivíduo
de uma forma que, antes de tudo,
acarreta um custo para A,
não acarreta benefícios diretos para A
e causa uma violação de
norma que não afetou A.
Por exemplo, eu estou de
pé numa longa fila
à espera de conseguir o meu iPad 2
e uma pessoa fura a fila atrás de mim.
Certo... ela cortou a
fila atrás de mim.
Isso não afeta o meu acesso ao iPad.
Eu poderia puni-la, convidando todo
mundo que está atrás dela
a passar na frente de nós 2.
Isso piora a minha condição, certo?
Acabei de deixar todo mundo
atrás de mim na fila
passar na minha frente.
Não me beneficia diretamente em nada.
E a coisa à qual eu estou causando um
dano ao indivíduo atrás de
mim não é algo que causou uma
violação de norma dirigida a mim.
Ela furou a fila atrás de mim.
E vemos vários exemplos de
comportamentos com essa estrutura
na literatura da economia
comportamental.
Lá estão eles, sabe-se lá o motivo.
Talvez porque seja uma forma de promover
um certo tipo de pró-sociabilidade
evolutivamente estável.
Talvez porque as violações de
norma tocam em heurísticas
que levam as pessoas a agirem de
determinadas maneiras.
Talvez por uma 3ª razão.
Parece que em inúmeros cenários,
em laboratório ou em locais públicos,
as pessoas se envolvem em atos punitivos
que têm a estrutura articulada acima.
O consequencialismo, pelo menos
na sua forma simples,
não pode explicar isso.
Finalmente, o estado de
espírito parece desempenhar
um grande papel na forma como é
que as pessoas respondem
a situações que potencialmente
envolvem a punição.
Vamos supor que o pobre Jim
venha até a minha casa e,
atrás da porta, está o meu
guarda-chuva favorito.
E Jim bate à minha porta e eu
digo a ele: "Entra".
Ele entra pela porta e passa por cima
do meu guarda-chuva favorito,
fazendo um grande estrago no
meu guarda-chuva.
E ele diz: "Oh não, o seu
guarda-chuva favorito...". Caso 1.
Caso 2. Jim aparece na minha casa.
E eu digo a ele:
"Jim, cuidado com o meu
guarda-chuva ao entrar!".
E Jim abre a porta e pisa no meu
guarda-chuva favorito,
fazendo um grande estrago nele, e diz:
"Oh droga, o seu guarda-chuva!".
Caso 3. Jim bate à minha porta.
Eu digo a ele: "Jim, cuidado com
o meu guarda-chuva!".
Jim abre a porta, pisa no meu
guarda-chuva favorito e
olhando para o estrago diz: "Yeah!
Estraguei o seu guarda-chuva!".
Que tipos de respostas
esses 3 casos evocam?
Aqui está o nosso famoso medidor-do-mau
que vocês bem lembram.
Quando Jim acidentalmente pisa
no meu guarda-chuva...
o 1ª caso em que eu disse "Entra, Jim"
e ele pisou nele e disse: "Oh
não, o seu guarda-chuva!".
Existe um dano, mas ele é
tratado como de baixo nível.
Quando eu digo para o Jim: "Cuidado
com o meu guarda-chuva!".
E, no entanto, o Jim abre a
porta e pisa nele e diz:
"Oh droga, o seu guarda-chuva!"...
ele fez algo negligente.
E há um sentido, por parte da
maioria dos indivíduos,
de que ocorreu algo ligeiramente pior
na direção geral do prejudicial.
E quando o Jim entra na minha casa
e pisa no meu guarda-chuva
e olha com orgulho para o que ele
fez, depois de ter sido,
ao que parece, intencional... há, por
parte da maioria dos indivíduos,
uma sensação de que algo pior ocorreu.
O consequencialismo sozinho
não pode explicar isso.
Em todos os 3 casos, eu tenho o meu
pobre guarda-chuva pisado.
O que pode explicar isso é uma resposta
que parece persistir em
todas as culturas,
o que às vezes é chamado o
fenômeno da indignação moral.
No caso do acidente, não há
indignação moral.
Ninguém pensa que foi moralmente
ultrajante por parte do Jim
pisar no meu guarda-chuva, uma
vez que ele não sabia
o que estava detrás da porta e
tinha acabado de chegar.
No caso negligente, há um
pouco de irritação,
há alguma indignação
moral, há um sentimento:
"Jim, eu disse que o meu
guarda-chuva estava aí!".
Mas a indignação moral é
relativamente baixa.
No caso em que Jim fez algo
que nos parece ter sido intencional,
uma violação direta do meu
pedido de não fazer isso
– "Jim, cuidado com o meu
guarda-chuva" –,
há uma resposta de alta
indignação moral.
E o que Carlsmith e Darley
sugerem no artigo que lemos
é que essas atitudes de
nenhuma indignação moral,
baixa indignação moral ou de
alta indignação moral
direcionam a nossa atenção para
diferentes partes do episódio.
Quando há um evento que não produz
nenhuma indignação moral,
não existe – exceto no que diz
respeito a um desejo geral
de tornar o mundo um lugar melhor –
nenhuma atenção seja para a
vítima ou para o infrator.
Coisas ruins acontecem.
Poderíamos investir na
tentativa de mudar o mundo.
Se há um suprimento extra de
guarda-chuvas no meu carro,
eu poderia pegar um deles.
Geralmente, quando as coisas
acontecem por acaso
o infrator não é um foco de atenção.
E a vítima não é tão
mais foco de atenção
se fosse uma rajada de vento que tivesse
provocado ao estrago do guarda-chuva.
Em casos de baixa indignação moral,
a atenção é dirigida para a vítima.
Há uma tendência de focar
a compensação,
na necessidade de tornar as
coisas melhores.
Mas não há nenhum foco no infrator
como alguém que necessita a
nossa atenção punitiva.
Mas no caso...
e num momento eu vou pedir para
vocês pegarem os clickers
porque vamos falar sobre a
ação intencional...
No caso em que o ato que
viola a norma moral
seja visto como tendo sido intencional,
há uma tendência a focar não
apenas na remuneração,
mas também na punição.
Esse é um padrão
extraordinariamente
resistente
e parece algo
psicologicamente
interessante
se estamos tentando
alcançar códigos morais
que visam a evolução dos seres
humanos, atacando-os com prazer.
Mas um problema com essa imagem
é que determinar se uma ação
foi feita intencionalmente
pode ser bem mais complicado do
que parecia ao início.
Portanto, o meu colega, junto ao
professor Joshua Knobe de Yale,
realizou uma série de estudos
sobre o que leva as pessoas a pensarem
numa ação como tendo sido
praticada intencionalmente.
E realizamos o estudo de
modo que todos vocês
recebam ambos cenários.
Não obtivemos exatamente a
distribuição indicativa
das respostas típicas.
Mas ainda assim é interessante
para que vocês possam
refletir através dos casos.
Então, quantos de vocês já
viram esses casos antes?
Levantem as mãos.
OK, em torno de 5 a 10%.
Josh Knobe apresenta
os os seguintes cenários às pessoas.
O vice-presidente de uma empresa
chegou no presidente do conselho
e disse: "Estamos pensando em
lançar um novo programa.
Ele vai nos ajudar a aumentar os lucros,
mas prejudicará o meio ambiente".
O presidente do conselho responde:
"Eu não me importo em
prejudicar o meio ambiente.
Eu só quero obter o máximo
de lucro possível.
Vamos lançar o novo programa".
E eles lançam o programa.
O meio ambiente é prejudicado.
A questão é esta: ao
lançar este programa
– "Eu não me importo em
prejudicar o meio ambiente,
só quero obter o máximo de lucro" –,
o presidente está prejudicando o meio
ambiente de forma intencional?
1) Sim, ele prejudica o meio
ambiente intencionalmente;
2) Não, ele não prejudica o meio
ambiente intencionalmente?
Uh? As pessoas não estão com os
seus clickers à mão.
Há apenas 70 respostas.
OK, vamos ver o resultado.
Então, 77% de vocês acham
que ele prejudica o meio
ambiente intencionalmente.
E vamos agora ao 2º caso.
2º caso... tentem esquecer o 1º.
Eu sei que vocês não podem fazer
isso, mas façam um esforço.
O vice-presidente de uma empresa
foi ao presidente do conselho e disse:
"Estamos pensando em lançar
um novo programa.
Ele vai nos ajudar a aumentar os lucros.
Mas também ajudará o meio ambiente".
O presidente do conselho responde:
"Eu não me importo em
ajudar o meio ambiente.
Eu só quero obter o máximo
de lucro possível.
Vamos lançar o novo programa".
E eles lançam o programa.
O meio ambiente é ajudado.
Portanto, o presidente diz:
"Eu não me importo em
ajudar o meio ambiente.
Eu só quero obter lucro".
Pergunta, o presidente ajuda o meio
ambiente de forma intencional?
1) Sim.
2) Não.
E vamos ver como saem os números.
Uau! Vocês são incríveis!
Tudo bem, vocês foram ainda mais
claros que os resultados normais
de Knobe, mesmo com os 2 casos
sendo expostos em sequência,
o que deveria ter atenuado o efeito.
Mas vamos lá...
Classicamente, quando isso é
apresentado às pessoas,
no 1º cenário onde 77% de
vocês disseram que sim,
ele prejudicou intencionalmente,
83% das pessoas dizem o mesmo.
Ao passo que, no 2º caso,
em que vocês deram estes incríveis 89%
de que ele ajudou o meio
ambiente intencionalmente,
normalmente esse número é de 23%.
Então este [não ajudou
intencionalmente] é um 67
... desculpe, 77%.
OK, o que está acontecendo aqui?
Deixa eu lembrar vocês o que
acaba de acontecer.
Tivemos 2 cenários idênticos.
A única diferença é que
mudamos o termo "ajudar"
para "prejudicar".
Em ambos os casos, o CEO diz:
"Eu não me importo com a
coisa que você acha
que eu fiz intencionalmente no 1º caso
e a coisa que você acha que não
fiz intencionalmente no 2º.
Eu só me importo em obter lucro".
Portanto, a maioria de vocês pensou
que ele tinha a intenção
de fazer algo que ele
ignorou no 1º caso.
Enquanto que, no 2º caso,
quase ninguém pensou
que ele tinha a intenção de
fazer algo ignorado por ele.
Isso é perturbador, se o objetivo aqui
é que a punição deve
acompanhar a ação intencional.
Porque parece que o tipo de ação
que pegamos para ser
intencional é, de alguma
forma,
confundido com o tipo de
ação que pegamos
para ser moralmente problemática.
Isso torna toda a questão de
como devemos pensar
sobre a punição ainda mais
complicada do que já é.
Mas vamos deixar isso
temporariamente de lado
e pensar nas implicações existentes
a partir dos resultados
psicológicos que estivemos
estudando.
Por um lado, parece que
prestar atenção
nos motivos retrospectivos ou
retribucionistas para a punição,
visando o reequilíbrio da
balança da justiça,
é psicologicamente obrigatório para uma
teoria do "sentir-se satisfeito".
Ou, pelo menos,
simplesmente olhar adiante
e pensar sobre as considerações
consequencialistas e a utilidade
não parece psicologicamente suficiente.
A questão é se, ao tomar a
psicologia humana a sério,
existe uma alternativa adicional.
E inúmeros psicólogos e
filósofos têm questionado
que se não olharmos para
trás e para frente,
para o desempenho do crime
como algo que exige um
reequilíbrio de justiça
ou para a utilidade que pode
trazer para a sociedade,
mas sim para o que
chamávamos de 3 e 4 na
nossa 1ª caracterização,
a restituição e a reabilitação
como as nossas motivações...
será que podemos, de alguma forma,
obter um modelo psicologicamente
satisfatório de punição,
onde o objetivo não é o
reequilíbrio ou a utilidade,
mas sim algum tipo de reparação?
Isso às vezes é chamado de justiça
retributiva ou reparadora.
E quem está intrigado com isso,
eu posso indicar um local
onde vocês podem ler
artigos sobre esse tema.
OK, isso encerra a 1ª parte
da nossa discussão:
as implicações
psicológicas da punição.
O que eu quero fazer nos
últimos 5 minutos
é falar sobre a
interação com a sorte.
E vamos começar a aula da terça
falando sobre a conexão no
contexto da parentalidade.
Bom, ao longo desta unidade estive
pensando em casos como este,
em que a sorte parece desempenhar um
papel nas consequências.
Quando a pessoa não tem a
intenção de causar dano.
O Celular Azarado e o Alberto Azarado
não desejavam causar dano à criança.
Mas, claro, a sorte pode
desempenhar um papel em casos
em que alguém está
deliberadamente tentando causar
danos.
Aqui está o nosso bandido padrão,
que aparece na cidade e encontra
uma vítima em potencial.
Ele saca a sua arma e diz:
"Aah, eu vou atirar nesse cara".
E a sorte está do lado dele.
A intenção se passa da forma
que ele pretendia...
e ele consegue.
O seu análogo perfeito, o Atirador
Azarado, aparece na cidade
e diz: "Aah, eu vou atirar nesse cara".
Mas quando ele puxa o
gatilho, infelizmente,
justo no momento em que a sua
bala atingiria a vítima,
passa um caminhão que estava na nossa
última história e detém a bala.
Portanto, ele não tem sucesso
no crime pretendido.
Observem que este é o
espelho do caso anterior.
A intenção nos 2 casos é a mesma.
A ação nos 2 casos é a mesma.
Mas, no 1º caso, o criminoso teve sorte
em relação ao objetivo pretendido.
Ele atirou no cara que
intencionava atirar.
Ao passo que, no 2º caso,
o criminoso teve azar na meta traçada.
Ele não conseguiu acertar a vítima.
A questão é:
por que punir este mais sério que este?
Que tipo de justificação
poderia estar na base disto?
E David Lewis, num texto um pouco
complicado, eu admito...
e prometo que vamos comentar
sobre ele nas seções
para entender a lógica do
seu argumento...
mas David Lewis sugere que a única
coisa que poderia justificar
o tratamento desse ato como válido
de mais punição que este
é se pensamos que está bem impor o
que ele chama de loteria penal.
O que ele diz é que, se nós
soubéssemos objetivamente
que numa ação de tiro em
que se puxa o gatilho
há 1 chance em cada 10 de
a ação falhar
e 9 em 10 de a ação ser bem sucedida,
então a punição é,
fundamentalmente, em nosso sistema
atual,
equivalente a ter de tirar um palito
de um conjunto de palitos,
onde 9 deles enviam para um
longo período de prisão
e 1 para um período curto.
E ele sugere que a nossa prática atual
é semelhante a isso ao percorrer uma
série de casos imaginários,
cada um dos quais, de acordo com ele,
possuindo a mesma
justificação de tirar um
palito.
Então, imaginem um
sistema que estabelece
que a intenção é igual nos 2 casos.
Os nossos 2 indivíduos aqui
tiraram os palitos deles.
Cada um tem 1 chance em 9 de
evitar o xadrez...
desculpem, 1 chance em 10.
E 9 chances em 10 de ir para a cadeia.
Tudo com base na sorte.
O equivalente a isso, diz Lewis,
não é o infrator tirar um palito...
mas que antes do julgamento,
um representante judicial
tire um palito.
E, embora o júri esteja
apenas decidindo se
"ele pretendeu fazer isso?",
eles não sabem de antemão
qual será a pena.
O equivalente a isso, ele
sugere, é que, de antemão,
o representante judicial tire um
palito e torne público
que se o júri condená-lo pela
intenção de praticar o crime,
então ele tanto receberá a pena de 9,
a mais grave, quanto a de 1.
O equivalente a isso, sugere Lewis,
é proporcionar, de antemão,
uma reconstituição do crime,
com probabilidades semelhantes, e se
a vítima morrer nesse caso,
então o indivíduo receberá
uma punição mais grave.
E, sugere Lewis, a nossa prática
de simplesmente deixar o
mundo atuar sozinho,
punindo mais severamente a pessoa
cuja tentativa de crime foi bem-sucedida
que aquela cuja tentativa de crime
não foi bem-sucedida, é apenas
uma pré-encenação, moralmente
equivalente a um reconstituição,
moralmente equivalente a tirar
palitos de forma aleatória.
Eu vou finalizar aqui, como uma
forma de tentar expor mais
uma vez a hesitação da moral, ou
talvez, a sorte imoral.
E vamos abrir a aula de terça com a
nossa discussão de Kazdin,
passando em seguida para a
nossa seleção
dos textos de Thomas Hobbes.
Amanhã eu publico o material.
Obrigada.